confie nez vous connaissez tous célèbre
stylo bille il a été inventé par le
baron bich en 1950 et nous nous sommes
tous s'interroger sur l'utilité de ce
petit trou il permet à l'encré de
s'écouler
et quand l'abbaye située à la pointe du
stylo roule sur le papier elle dépose de
lancre mais pour laisser sa trace en
continu elle doit son enrobé en
permanence si le stylo est
hermétiquement fermées comme ici l'air
ne pourrait pas pénétrer à l'intérieur
aucune pression ne s'exercerait sur la
colonne d'entre pour la pousser jusqu'à
l'abbaye
on ne pourrait pas écrire pas même une
capsule de des conflits grâce à ce petit
trou l'air pénétré à l'intérieur du silo
la pression est alors là même à
l'intérieur qu'à l'extérieur c'est la
pression atmosphérique qui agit sur la
colonne d'encre et la pousse jusqu'à
l'allier si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
vous pouvez également revoir celle des
jours précédents cliquant sur le côté en
haut ou en bas je réalise une nouvelle
chaque jour pour être sûr de ne pas en
rater
abonnez-vous est activée la petite
cloche ali à demain et n'oubliez pas
nous sommes confinés
mais on reste en dire